digamos que la economía de los eeuu está
entrando en una recesión o en algo peor
y usted es el presidente de la reserva
federal y necesita hacer algo al
respecto bueno lo primero que usted va a
hacer es bajar la tasa de los fondos
federales que es la tasa en la que los
bancos se prestan mutuamente y la forma
de hacer esto es una vez que usted
indica que quiere bajarlo es que se va a
imprimir dinero se imprime dinero como
reserva federal y se usa para comprar
normalmente títulos del tesoro a corto
plazo y ese dinero se deposite en bancos
por lo que la demanda por las reservas
que es esto la demanda por las reservas
va a bajar los suministros van a
aumentar y la tasa de los fondos
federales deberá bajar pero qué pasa si
seguimos haciendo esto y seguimos
bajando la tasa de los fondos federales
de manera que la tasa de interés de
préstamo interbancario va a llegar a 0%
que se hace entonces la economía sigue
cayendo en picada bueno ustedes pueden
continuar imprimiendo dinero
pero no se usa para comprar títulos de
tesoro a corto plazo porque eso no ayuda
en nada a la tasa de interés
interbancaria a corto plazo así que lo
que pueden hacer es comprar otras cosas
comprar otras cosas y entre estas otras
cosas pueden ser títulos de tesoro a
largo plazo títulos del tesoro a largo
plazo o podría ser otro tipo de valores
se pueden comprar valores respaldados
con hipotecas o se puede comprar deuda
comercial
y esta idea de imprimir dinero no solo
para modificar una tasa de interés
específica sino esencialmente para usar
ese dinero ponerla en circulación y
quizás afectar otros elementos del
mercado a esto se le llama
flexibilización cuantitativa
flexibilización cuantitativa y en la
mente del presidente de la reserva
federal es exactamente lo que se hace
imprimir dinero para comprar cosas que
afectan la tasa de interés de préstamo
interbancario y él lo llama
flexibilización de crédito y en su mente
aunque mecánicamente son lo mismo en su
mente él se dice que se imprime ese
dinero no solo para poner dinero en
circulación se imprime dinero para poder
comprar bienes particulares que
parecieran que podrían obstruir la
entrada del mercado de créditos ya que
al imprimir dinero para comprar valores
del gobierno quizás la tasa de interés
en la deuda del gobierno baje pero
quizás por razones de pánico o de crisis
o porque los precios en estos elementos
no se comportan adecuadamente
para arreglar eso se usa la
flexibilización de crédito que sirve
para comprar ese tipo de bienes